c'est un plat je crois que typiquement
savoyard carrément nous propose en fait
cette calme plat des pays où il ya du
fromage et surtout du fromage du coup
hier jean oui mais vous allez nous
proposer quelques dérivés à cette folie
c'est exact
nous allons commencer par faire une
réduction de bière hall a commencé le
début d'un va commencer par une
réduction de bien c'est dans ma soeur
c'est une recette à 0,7 alors pendant
que cette bière va arriver nous nous
ferons autre chose car on doit aussi
parce qu'ils demandent le plus de temps
c'est ça alors voilà nous allons parler
des fromages qui servent à faire la
fondue naturellement défendue il y en a
beaucoup
brillat savarin dans le 1 son fameux
livre la physiologie du goût parle d'une
fondue qui étaient en réalité des oeufs
brouillés autre hommage parce que
allemande personne n'est d'accord avec
voyez à savoir à ce sujet
absolument personne ceux qui parlent
aussi d'un certain prêtre qui avait
mangé et la fondue avec une cuillère ce
qui ne se faisait pas un pli risque mais
résident se marchent toujours avec une
prochaine c'est bien nous allons parler
aussi du fromage de gruyère
ceci est du fromage de chalais c'est
d'un mental et c'est un fromage qui
convient parfaitement à la fabrication
de ce que nous voulons faire des
réformes ou à écouter quelques lamelles
par instant là parce qu'il fait couper
quelques la m alors vous savez que les
savoyards et dans la montagne ne le
coupent pas le fromage comme je vais le
faire il le coupe à la main il le coupe
comme ce scénario en petits morceaux
comme ça avec le couteau conseil oui ce
serait trop long alors je le juge en
parle tout de même et je vais donner mes
références parce que je sais que lorsque
l'on parle de ouhlala d'un plat régional
régional
j'aurais peut-être convenablement mais
une certaine tension prestation alors je
vais donner tout une référence j'ai
appris à faire à la fondue à l'école de
haute montagne lorsque les cols de haute
montagne de chamonix était installé à
l'alpe d'huez
alors comme principaux comment dirais-je
professeur j'ai eu emile allais et toute
son équipe
désolé si ça mais c'est cher mais si
mais si c'est que si les les fils de
boulanger là bas dans ce pays tout le
monde sait faire la fondue alors ce sont
mes références je vais la faire
exactement si vous faites autrement bien
fait non je n'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit que
celle que j'ai ri faire je me réfère de
mes sources
bien que parfois c'est comme si on veut
rouspéter très bien tout le monde
connaît l'adresse des mille ans que
j'écris aura lieu à écouter mon vieux
vous avez très mal appris à faire la
peau du r'n'b autrement dit courrier la
voyez avec mon c'est ça oui le pab la
veille à moi prière d'envoyer
directement un mineur
c'est gentil simple aloïs iwai rouge et
la réduction de bière mais qui n'a rien
à voir avec la fonte du coup je voudrais
dire la vie dans des bons instants alors
nous allons faire ici un ersatz de
fondue en quelque sorte cette alliance
vient
non non pas du tout coller tous comment
c'est fait qu'il faut jamais reçus là je
vais mettre un petit peu de fromage de
geste et alors là le voyage et festayres
est une véritable merveille
voici les fromages de chez stern les
anglais l'euro ni les environs ni
totalement gelée l'angleterre on y voit
un geste est rivaux disais qu'est ce que
c'est ça
leicester ne connaît pas on le dit mais
vous savez ce que c'est que le cheddar
ah oui dit très bientôt
cheddar rédaction tout ce que c'est que
ces dames mais les chaînes ne savons pas
or ce format la city comme en anglais
ils passent en phase où ne restaient
îles et régions isolées récollets
angleterre alors actuellement la
l'importation année interdite je les ai
eus - en ford avait un monsieur
l'éloigner et ont laissé passer ce
morceau de fromage dans la valise d'un
mes amis c'était pareil mais alors il
est où ce fromage ces affaires le welsh
larbi nous allons faire ouais nan c'est
une fondue une fondue qui nous couvrons
tout à l'heure abc la femme heures
aujourd hui avec la fameuse bière qui
réduit mais pour le moment nous allons
faire une autre spécialité qui se fait
moitié moi qui a pour l'instant
hier il restait alors boyer a lâché ster
que nous donne en mélangeant son affaire
nous nous qui pouvons pas la faire
entrer en fraude
il faut pas faire entrer ce pas bien
vous la ferez que définie grira que
décrié à l'arrière goût du vin blanc
alors là nous aimons retombé presque
toujours sur la même le même système
c'est à dire le vin blanc doit juste
pour ouvrir le froid ça alors ça c'est
important
un blanc doit couvrir le fromage là tout
petit peu plus et c'est suffisant bon eh
bien nous allons préparer un peu plus de
leicester pour faire le watch qui lui ne
prend pas du tout le gruyère
ah bon uniquement et gestion mais ce qui
se pratique aussi c'est aussi une ville
à l'aide ça alors là ça relance en
championnat
merci cola escoffier escoffier sur toute
la ligne référencées ce quartier mais là
il n'y a pas besoin d'ailleurs on
pouvait se référer je pourrais dire que
c'est un vieil ami irlandais à moi qui
m'a enseigné à la faire je mentirais pas
faire ce serait quand même valeur c très
bien ça ferait bien oui mais c'est pas
vrai ce travail alors je le dis pas
c'est très serré au fond c'est ce terre
coupées en dés ce temps là mes
casseroles chauffe avec quelque chose
dedans a bien réduit oui il a bien
réduit entre et du poivre de cayenne de
la moutarde de loi il y trouve tout à
l'heure et je m'en vais ici voiliers ont
alors forcé mais alors précisé mme nous
bien parce que qu'on ne mélange pas les
différentes recettes 1 500 études ceci à
l'étude je vais m dans celle-ci du
poivre comme si je vous dis plus rien
j'essaie de vous arrêter mis là oui et
je m'ai fait enfants lesquels sa fondue
d'hydrogène ne soit pas fini je
m'occuperai de la seconde fondé et je
mettrai tout ça au chaud tranquillement
pour tout à l'heure les finir
rios ça va très très
la bienvenue en pc le feu et nous avons
obtenues je vais retourner beaucoup il
faut retourner rapidement mais il faut
tout vous savez c'est une question de
dosage
quand c'est très bien dosé au départ il
n'y a plus aucun problème si c'est mal
dosée ça fait du coach ou et c'est cette
absolue jusqu'à lors plusieurs le
tripote alors le plus onéreux autour de
votre dosage est ce que vous nous avez
donné cette précision justement pour pas
le racheter
oui je vous ai dit il faut couvrir bon
et bien ici ça suffit la tenir au chaud
bon cette casserole jeune réalisateur
demande que ceci quels enseignements
alors voyez vous ma bière est
entièrement réduite dit rien ou presque
rien mais alors là je vais mettre le ch
esther dedans et je vais rajouter la
bière christ la quantité est essentielle
ça donne du coup kaka réduite elle donne
beaucoup plus de coups que si j'avais
simplement couvert avec de la bière ce
que je vais faire maintenant inférieure
et où j'avais simplement maintenant
comment mais j'ai réduit d'abord la
pierre c'est extrêmement important
d'abord un peu de bière réduite et
ensuite on court le j'espère car là il
n'y a que du ch est que des j'espère
alors voyez vous c'est très important
qu'au départ il y ait suffisamment de
liquide car s'il n'ya pas suffisamment
nikica fondera toujours sa foi dans même
d'une façon beaucoup plus esthétique en
quelques leçons ce massacre des coachs
ou alors ça c'était important
laissons l'esthétique de côté pour une
fois n'est ce pas oui enfin pas trop
quand même un délai sont pas trop
l'esthétique respectons là un peu
respectons les règles de l'art comme le
dit la chanson et mettons un peu de
poivre de cayenne à celui-là dans
l'autre j'ai mis du poids andy nombre
d'efforts du moulin du coran loyaux là
ça paraît même système dès que ça bouffe
or je baisse le feu et je repère le
mélange de la fondue en tournant et en
tournant rapidement mais met tout de
même en donnant et c'était que ça
sont si j'ose dire ces mots aussi bien
que le yen ou peut-être même mieux
peut-être même mieux c'est un fromage
des plus friables
vous savez on fait des fondus aussi bien
avec du fromage de vache que du fromage
de chèvre que du vacherin etc
on fait des fondus avec tous les
fromages fins selon la raclette du
valais différente de la fondue du
comment dirais-je du grésivaudan n'est
ce pas ou derrière
mais il est un fait évident c'est que
les fonds du son de chaque pays et
chacun à sa tête son petit système pas
son fromage etc
alors la deûle en donner un tout petit
peu plus d'intensité pour réduire un
tout petit peu notre village qui est
très très très bien voyez-vous là c'est
très important pour qui le fondu comme
ceux ci soient ce ne ne passe pas de
coach où il est important qu'elle soit
faite rapidement là et bien ça c'est
terminé aussi bien nous allons nous
occuper maintenant selon le temps que
nous allons avoir de faire une troisième
fondu ou bien au contraire de nous
occuper d'une répondu non et je ne crois
pas avoir le temps je vais donc
m'occuper de faire la première fondu
avec du bacon ou bien du trône de fer
avec du jambon jambon alors là c'est du
jambon de bayonne enfin style bayonne du
jambon sec
je vais couper les trajectoires en fine
ça c'est pour la première recette là
c'est pour la première c'est celle qui
est moitié gruyère moitié gestion qui
devrait être entièrement gruyère si
voilà alors l'heure c'est suffisant pour
il s'agit d'affaires pour une personne
non seulement à vélo vers cet autre moi
je le fond du mont saint vite on est
nombreux
oui mais là on s'en est amusé des plats
oui mais c'est pas du tout ça vous allez
voir là nous allons faire la fondue qui
va se manger comme ça et plus encore les
fondus ces deux là qui comme le welsh
arbitres et comme la fondue que je fais
ici ne sont pas des fonds dès que l'on
mange comme ça autour d'une table non
c'est pas drôle
ici on va la faire c'est le comminges
autodata a fait rossi alors là deux
tonnes et p
et vous à ses effets de bons centimètres
d'épaisseur
j'enlève le lac route
je vais faire griller au four se paie
des deux côtés bon alors j'ouvre le faut
mais le père dessus en deux plaques de
plaire deux places n'est ce pas comme
ceux ci et je m'en vais reprendre ici la
première la première de mes fondu que je
vais reprendre qui a failli et autres
élites il au départ l'espace c'est à
dire qu'il va pouvoir rêver en tout qui
peut se mélanger à nouveau
bon ça c'est pas si chaud comment
pourrais je faire pour que ça soit plus
chaud je pense qu'il faudrait sur la
c'est pour la première fois c'est pour
très bien pardon merci ça a l'air de
bien aller là je pense samedi 2 mai d un
petit peu mais ce qui vous le demande
même pas de ça est trop fort je suppose
non la merci à la tournée là c'est très
bien capté merci et puis l'autre aussi
puisque je vais le faire tous les deux
en même temps
alors voilà rapidement et où je vais
mettre dans cette fondue le jambon tels
que et je vais donner un tout petit tour
juste pour qu'ils prennent en quelque
sorte qu'ils deviennent homogène avait
acquis ce mélange qui se met la lumière
la voilà et le payer les voici
ford ont alors une tranche de pain
grillé s'il doit leur grille est là et
puis nous allons verser sur les deux sur
ces deux terrains après l'avoir bien
mélanger nous allons verser le premier
mélange comme ceux ci c'était une dérive
et mais c'est vraiment très sympathique
voilà est ici pour le welsh de la même
façon exactement la même passion hélas
cette recette là vraiment on ne peut pas
se faire avec autre chose qu'avec duché
spurs est à l'honneur non il n'en est
pas question d'ailleurs comme vous nous
dites comment donc pas là et nous allons
garder ceci pendant quelques secondes au
chaud alors d ajouter du jambon là rien
rien eu
les chiens sont dus simplement bon de
reprendre ici une occasion de terre et
nous allons préparer plus le fonds fait
cette casserole de terre nous allons la
frottée à l'ail au fond largement et les
chaudes mais ça c'est pour moi pour rien
la faute à l'ail la fota est fortement
je pars sans l'année c'est ce sont bien
deux bon alors là je vais couper une
jambe bord du pendage l'aiguillé en
assez grande quantité parce que là je
vais faire a répondu alors celle ci
classique l'on mange
il ya quelque chose que j'ai oublié
catherine c'était très important
j'ai oublié de mettre de la moutarde sur
le pain qui était destiné à faire le
white rabbit le web seulement
et ça c'est très important c'est un
oubli je vais retrouver derrière
et oui mais je vais le réparer tout de
suite en mettant voyez-vous de la
moutarde sur le dos de cette cuillère et
en trotteur sur celle là n'est ce pas
confondre pas celle qui a des jambes non
uniquement le wesh
c'est un oubli important que je répare
en oui oui on espère donc je ne fut
jamais pardonnable je ne cherche pas
d'excusés d'ailleurs je dis je les ai
oubliés je répare aussi vite que
possible
bon et bien ici connaissait la question
maintenant aussi bien que moi dans le
coupé des jeux viennent de griller de la
julien nom de remis au point en quelques
sortes les petits cubes
évidemment plus et on ne peut pas le rap
et qu'on peut le rappeler on peut le
rappeler seulement ça ne se fait pas
alors pourquoi faurecia le rythme mais
il est évident que j'ai essayé souvent
de la râpée et j'espère forcément bien
réussir parfaitement bien réussi
seulement il est un fait c'est que on ne
doit pas le faire alors que nombre en
règle
- soyons sérieux alors oui à la haute où
les coups alors là il m'a dit monsieur
je ne serai jamais je n'aurais pas pu
dire que c'était pas vrai je n'ai pas pu
donner ma référence la fameuse de
référence pour une fois qu'un événement
passé si j'en crois certains alors là ça
y est voilà le fromage coupé alors là tu
vas non je pouvais bien qu'il était
intéressant et ça se comprend d'ailleurs
ça coule de source
qu'ils soient à couper régulièrement
parce que il faudra donc les passions
vos conclusions me gêne beaucoup plus
régulièrement si au départ
bon et bien ici nous allons la place
gaston je vous dis a été alliée nous
allons ajouter tout de suite du poivre
de cayenne en petite quantité et un peu
de poivre du moulin
un petit ajoute également à dire moitié
moitié il pose de gaines n'empêche dans
le riche et du poids ordinaire dans le
jeu cela pas de notre spécialité pour
pouvoir
oui c'est un jeu de sons et fantaisie
les fantaisies que la base de fonds du
foie il ya la cause a des qualités on
peut la faire avec des tranches de bacon
grillé c'est ce que je réfléchisse
j'avais eu un peu plus de temps alors là
je vais aller doucement compte pas le
cas c'est l'ensemble de ce nom alors je
vais essayer le protéger ma casserole
avec une vraie car il faut toujours le
faire d'une question de terre et c'est
pourquoi c'est très important
bon je vais essayer de faire ça comme ça
alors maintenant voyez où j'ai couvert
simplement couverts alors il y a il y
avait un système qui consistait à peser
chaque chose ont pesé le fromager peser
le liquide
il faut en principe je crois je n'en
sais rien l'accord est une simple ces
deux tiers de poids de liquide pour les
l'unité de fromage je ne suis pas
tellement certain alors je ne vais pas
vous le dire non parce que j'ai tout de
même un poids assez considérable de
fromage oui eh bien voyez où ça va pas
voir absolument que j'aille
mettre le feu à la casserole non je vis
normalement il ne faut pas le faire le
gaz est une chose qui est très violente
c'est évidemment un des meilleurs
chauffage possible mais cet effet qui le
mans violent en principe là il ya
beaucoup de liquide ça ne veut pas ça ne
veut rien risquer 3 évidemment ça va
tomber plus vite et la cadence hier la
ford il faut avoir sur la table alors là
oui là il faut d'urgence
on pourrait le préparer à l'internaute
et puis un petit réchaud sur la fin oui
un petit réchaud ça c'est une bonne
chose en soi ça le pain comme ceux ci
ont le couple a le sens de la longueur
puis encore dans la salle de la longueur
il faut vous le disiez parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui n'ont jamais fait
pour qu'il y ait alors là encore comme
ceci vous allez voir et puis ongles
comme ceux ci ont cure qui arrive est
très important quand on met sa
fourchette dans un morceau alors là il
ya eu le combine d'ailleurs que je vais
vous apprendre parce que elle est
elle-même importante à savoir il faut
cliquer là la croûte du pain et non pas
la mi temps quand on pique la route le
moteur est pas d'accord vous savez qu'il
y a
en ayant chacun une amende une amende
qui est sévère c'est lui laisse tomber
sa petite bouteille de vin de savoie
pour chaque morceau de pain qui restait
dans le dollar dans la casserole et ça
va très bien ça se passe très bien c'est
vrai il faut le temps de la faune
d'ailleurs en iran le mans vous voyez
vous dans les deux cas dans les trois
cas même puisque c'est trois fois que
j'ai fait de la forme et il faut qu'elle
soit relativement liquide au départ et
elle va revenir elle va s'épaissir
alors l effet si beaucoup en cours de
dégustation n'est ce pas parce qu'au fur
et à mesure que l'on remue avec le
morceau de terre on ne mange pas aussi
vous mâche pas aussi vite qu'elle réduit
qu'elle chauffe
alors elle réduit toujours mais
néanmoins le sera très bien devenir
général
très épaisse quand on arrive au fond de
la casserole oui de là le nombre de
raquettes d'ailleurs je pense que ça
vient de là c'est oracle le fromage le
fromage qui justement a très cuit il est
cuit alors on prépare les morceaux de
pain mais alors là la raclette en chacun
ne se sert pas il ya quelqu'un qui sert
les autres qui prépare à la raquette
c'est en quelque sorte la question il ya
un sac et qui est normalement ça c'est
moi en commun qui doit être sacrifiée
alors j'aime autant faire de la faune du
corps alors je vais ajouter à cette
fondue et au ramenant un tout petit peu
vite
je vais ajouter un petit peu de kirsch
on roule je vous l'avais là je crois que
les préparer dans une petite dans une
petite société
pourquoi vous allez me dire je dis ceci
parce que je sais pas s'il a versé comme
seriez-vous pendant la bouteille
seulement les bouteilles surtout
bénéficiant ce n'est pas la quantité que
l'on à des étiquettes dessus au risque
de faire de publicité
oui aussi oui allez vous regarder l'art
et bien je crois que je vais pouvoir
laisser ma là je vais faire gratiner
d'ici là il faut en effet d'attirer les
autres et faire gratiner pendant ce
temps là la faune du fsi voyez-vous il
arrive à sa consistance normal elle est
bien homogène et vaud elle ne file pas
et le coup le sans fil et c'est très
important parce que la fondue qui file
était difficile à à sectionner wii reste
difficile envoyez là elle va bien en ce
qu'il faut et où c'est au départ avoir
juste le dosage voulu alors là
maintenant pour la laisser doucement
est-ce qu'il faut la laisser cuire
pendant un bon moment de la savine ont
maintenant changé
après le fond du hall à l'aise comme sur
la vie je suis anti réchauffement
voilà les deux autres sangsues qui
semble les deux autres prendre je vais
vous présenter en même temps celle ci
n'a pas patiné ce lien je vais la
laisser encore quelques secondes et tous
nous écoutons et manière quelque chose
pardon alors les petits croûtons oui si
vous voulez bien on va les mettre sur
une assiette
nous allons faire voir comment il s'agit
de montgueux car ça c'est très important
mon avis nous avons encore tout à fait
le tour nous pour en reparler même si
vous voulez que je viens je viens pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de confusion entre les
différentes recettes mais il fait beau
ici particulièrement chaud bon et bien
voici le welsh d'une part suggéré
on a bien fini merci copains d'une part
le web comment vous écrivez ça pour qui
ni wls c'est cela justement plus journal
est alors celle là avec le jambon n'est
ce pas est une gratinées au jambon ce
sont en quelque sorte latine et aux
jambes on vit ça se sent en quelque
sorte des hors-d'oeuvre chaud mais les
anglais le manger en fin de repas avant
avant les fruits ou france après le
fromage même ils appellent ils appellent
ça les favoris c'est un savoureux en
réalité le welsh rabbit est un favori
mais cette mode absolument pas c'est en
tout cas en france on en mange plus une
savory comme ça à présent repas ça ne se
fait plus sur ces félons voulez vous que
nous parlions alors maintenant de la
façon de manger leur font débat enfin
non alors voyons pic très bien on laisse
dépasser un petit peu alors on tourne
comme ceci et voila voila on mange à la
4e' alors voyez à la commande pas manger
devant non enfer où la commande au père
on tourne comme ceci
voici comment on fait alors il n'y a pas
on amène avec soi juste ce qui est
nécessaire
voyez vous alors on court toujours
soutenu chacun à son tour tourne un pic
et voyelles ne file pas et la main le
juste ce qu'il faut avec sur la
fourchette sur le mot est bien parce
qu'elle a été mouillé suffisamment tout
est dans la question des mouillages
alors nous avons donc si vous voulez que
nous répétions lowell genre beat qui est
fabriqué avec du fromage de shechter
fondu dans de la bière réduite
n'est ce pas et dans lequel on a on à
moutarde et le le minent le père de me
rappeler là aussi c'est à dire qu'il a
bien réduit depuis on a couvert de bien
oui on a recouvert de bienservi on a
remis la bière nécessaire pour faire
front on l'a fait fondre et une fois
qu'il a été fondue la vancouver ont
recouvert une toast avec nous avons
repéré la même façon lorsqu'il s'agit de
lorsqu'il s'agit de faire un test de
gratiné avec du jambon
mais au lieu de mettre du gestionnaire
ont mélangé de chester et du coup y est
ollier comme quoi les fromages se mêlant
ses militants pour ça et du vin blanc au
lieu devient du vin blanc lieu de pierre
et le loup ont fait une vraie fondu que
voilà et alors qu' elle est faite avec
uniquement du fromage de gruyère du vin
blanc du kirsch du poivre et de l'art du
tir ça c'est important car il faut
toujours des civils avaient fondu à lui
qui fait quelque chose on l'a mais au
dernier moment le cuir champ libre au
dernier moment le mais lorsque la fondue
et bien fondue est bien le mot j'ai
alors il est où celle ci est vraiment
bien homogène et elle ne file pas elle
se garde bien c'était ce qui leur est
gérée et 10 à différents âges d'or
oui vous avez des besoins tout de même
la mettre là pour qu'on puisse content
et bien mais au rythme très bien que ce
ne soit pas le visage puisqu'elle doit
rester sur le oui c'est pour ça que je
n'ai pas fait d'ailleurs il faut mettre
un petit réchaud électrique au milieu de
la danse ce soir là alors tous autour de
la table et puis ne laissez pas tomber
votre proton dedans cela vous coûterait
une bouteille de vin c'est ça de sa voix
[Musique]